my guest tonight start on the popular tv
series scrubs
and wrote directed and starting the
acclaimed film garden state
he also has a podcast fake doctors real
friends
with former scrubs co-star donald faison
please welcome
our friend zach braff zach really good
to see you
hi everybody are you gonna add
thunderous applause in right now
well actually no we're gonna add uh sort
of a wind growing acro
blowing across the prairie and the sound
of a single tumbleweed
could i if i could put in a request for
what sounds like a just a standing
ovation of just
just elation okay it'll be that
or crickets we have a we have a cricket
sound we've really wanted to try
recently so
let me figure out we're going to figure
it out but i'll i'll do
something to make you feel real happy i
promise it's
nice to see you because it's a breath of
life normalcy
because you know when you're doing these
zoom things
in your life it's usually the same bunch
of people you don't really see anybody
new
i know the fact that i look at you right
now i feel so happy
no me too i actually i feel like i'm
getting my dose of zach brath which
sounds dirty but it's not
i feel i feel i'm always happy to see
you
and yeah you're right we're we're all
living first of all how are you doing
during quarantine
you you seem like you're usually such a
peppy person how are you
i'm i'm glad i'm a little mad i'm sure
like everyone there's been there's been
phases where
i'm i'm i'm like oh this is great we
don't have to do anything
and then i have phases where i start to
go just insane
yeah yeah if you're anything like me i'm
i alternate between
seeing the silver lining of oh this is
kind of nice and then i swing to the
other side and i kill and kill again
i just i just i really like exercising a
lot because the only way i can stay
mentally sane is to exercise like
cardio so um i i i do think that uh i do
think this whole thing is going to
ironically make me in really good shape
so wait what kind of exercise are you
doing in your home
spinning on a peloton bike because i
thought you know
when's the next time i'm ever going to
go to a gym so i need to get one of
those
now um so you're pretty religious about
the peloton
i do i do it five days a week just
because um in endorphins wise it makes
me feel
slightly something a little bit like
happiness for about
a half hour afterwards here's my issue i
don't know if you had this issue
but when i was doing the peloton for a
bit and it didn't matter if it was a
woman or a man
but because it was kovid i started to
feel like i was having a relationship
with them i really i started to feel
like it's time
you know i need my time with brittany
right now or i need my time with
with uh with chris and um you know it's
funny you get loyal to some of the
teachers and then you're like
well i i don't want to upset so and so
but i think i might
i think i might try a class with this
person and then you feel like
i feel like i need to write them a
letter and say it's time i saw someone
else on peloton
which is not just not a good thing um
you know you've had this movie that you
made the comeback trail
yes sir and because of kovid it keeps it
it got pushed
to next year as a lot of movies have
yeah this is a very big project for you
because you got to
work with one of your all-time heroes
and think a lot of people's all-time
hero robert de niro
yeah conan this is what this is how
covid extra um
effed me up is that i had one of the
biggest breaks of my life
in that i got cast as a lead with robert
de niro in a giant comedy
directed and written by george gallo who
made midnight run one of my favorite
yep and i didn't even audition they
offered it to me i was like
but wait a minute it's a big part like
i'm on every page
and they were like yeah the deniro and
george want you for it
so i go down there we shoot it in
albuquerque
i'm it's literally me and de niro in
every scene we played
fantastic yeah movie producers who uh
who are just the worst movie producers
and um and and then covet hits and now
it's not coming out until next year
it'll come out but i was so excited
i mean this is just a still from the
movie but this is you
in bed with robert de niro and it's like
it's clear that you guys have
i mean there's no way you didn't get
intimately close with this man he became
very close and i had to i would i would
i'm not exaggerating that i would
because i
love him so much and i would go in in my
trailer in the mirror i would give
myself
pep talks i would be like you need to go
into this scene because i'd have scenes
where i'm screaming at them am i
slapping them across the face
and we're like and i would just give
myself a pep talk like this is just a
normal actor
this is not the most legendary hero that
you have
right right and so because i knew that
if i if i was intimidated i would suck
so i had to like
every scene i would give myself this
like mental like you got this
and that worked out yeah it was great
you know he's very shy
a lot of people don't know this about
him but he's but you know when he's not
in character
they call cut and he's kind of like you
know a quiet guy he goes back to his
chair
and then they go okay bob we're ready
and he comes to set and he's kind of
quiet
and then they yell action and he goes
full amazing de niro but he's pretty
soft spoken but little by little we
became um we became closer and
i mean it's a texting status which was
thrilling we just texted another day
you text now with robert de niro bobby d
our text buddies
sometimes he calls me out of the blue
because uh you know when you get like um
you know when you get um a no caller id
and you're like i'm not gonna answer
that who the hell could that be
right now i know that it potentially is
bob de niro so now i always answer it
of course nine times out of ten it's a
cold caller but one out of ten times
conan
it's bob just saying hi do you have a
special voice cause sometimes i pick up
the phone
when it says no caller id i take a
chance but i don't use my voice
yes yeah a tough guy voice it's like
yeah
what hello i do uh crazy over-the-top
italian guy or whether you want them
from me
and uh the eddie murphy bit in um i'm
sorry i have a horrible eddie murphy
impression but when he
on snl when he'd go this is how you
answer the door in my neighborhood
who is it
not bad i think that that i don't think
that was a terrible eddie murphy
impression
well i just always laughed at that's
what i channel when i when i answer the
no caller id
hello let's talk about uh you have a
podcast
with your with your uh old co-star and
buddy
uh donald faison you guys have this
podcast where you
talk about scrubs yeah well when before
code happened
you know someone approached us and said
the two two gals from the office had
done this and it becomes
really popular yeah he said you guys
ever want to do this and
they and they said you know you just sit
around and you watch it's not live you
watch the episode beforehand and then
you sit around and joke about it
right so don and i said it was great
that'll be fun yeah a blast
then coven starts and literally the day
we were set to record they locked down
the city
and we said oh that's too bad that would
have been fun it actually they said
don't worry we'll bring you the
the fancy microphone which i have here
oh that's the old
xk11320 oh you know it is the uh
yeah you probably actually know what it
is i don't know it brought us the gear
and
once a week we do it on zoom and we
thought it would just be like
i honestly thought it would be a handful
of scrubs fans and then like our parents
but it became huge internationally huge
and um so once a week we tell stories we
we go on long-ass random tangents
we make each other laugh we tell
nostalgic embarrassing anecdotes
and it's become huge that's great
that's fantastic the um the only thing
that's weird is that
i thought it was a joke at first but
donald says that he is
broadcasting from a closet in his house
yes and then i found out that it's real
he really does
broadcast from his closet yes because
donald is encoded with two small
children who want to know
where the hell dad is right and so his
initial plan was
i have to hide from these kids and our
engineer was like actually your closet's
not bad because of all the
acoustics will be great so but now he
like barricades himself in the closet so
that the kids of course now
after doing it this many episodes they
come in there it's funny
we just start having it be i thought it
i mean this reminds me of you because i
think you once told me when i was in the
show like i like to show the scenes like
if there's a message
show it mistakes mistakes are gold you
want mistakes you want people to see
that it's real
right and i actually it's funny i didn't
even think of this when i was going to
come on the show but i thought i thought
of you telling me that years ago because
we had stuff where it's like
his wife comes on and she's like honey
the exterminator's here he has to spray
the closet and
and we're like okay so we just we like
we don't we don't edit that stuff out
the exterminator comes in we start
talking to him about being an
exterminator
like you know his daughter uh i mean we
just we just have it all come on here on
the show because it's just it's funny
now i want to ask you uh i know a little
bit about the podcast business and
merchandising
yes i was surprised the minute you start
working in the podcast world
uh the merch people come to you and say
you need merch you need merchandising
and i didn't think that they were
serious because i thought but apparently
that's that's been a big thing for you
guys it's been a little bit of a journey
the merchandise conan you learned this
from i'm sure your
your show that they come to you and they
go oh just you know because i wasn't
super into podcasts i mean like
a handful of them but i i've been on a
bunch but they say this is a little bit
of a trivial
trivia not trivia a anecdotal what's the
word it's a thing podcast fans love they
love
merch they like a mug with their
favorite show they like a t-shirt
and we were like okay we've never made
merch for anything but sure
so we put out some [ __ ] t-shirt and
a mug and the fans
on all our social media started making
fun of us like what is this
horrible merch it was it wasn't good
merch no they did not like their merch
it was basically just our logo with on a
shirt or a mug
so donald and i get very competitive
we're we're very competitive people we
did not like this angle
so we said we're going all in we are
going to spend more time coming up
with with random ass merch for the
people
right so we did that all right so let me
ask you something because i have
something here and i don't know what's
going on
this looks to be this looks to be a hand
towel is this a hand towel
it's a washcloth okay here's the deal
with this
donald donald had brought this whole
theory on to the
um to the podcast that
conan that's yours by the way to keep i
get to keep this
yes thank you donald has this theory
that african-american people universally
bring a washcloth in the shower
whereas caucasians don't ha
and then it began we have an
african-american female producer and she
weighed in heavily saying yes all of her
african-american friends also bring
washclaws in the shower
interesting from the south started
weighing in said no it's not just about
that it says it's where you grew up
people from the south bring wash closet
so this joke about wash cloths in the
shower became a running gag
and we said you know what we're making
we're making the people
uh watch claws so this i can take into
the shower with me
i know you can watch your mom you're
supposed to wash your butt with it
wait your butt you're supposed to wash
your butt with it yeah that's the idea i
think i think
you think you have to know you can't
tell me to do that on a whim
i need to first of all that's not what i
would have thought i would not have
thought
i would have thought oh you use it to
put the hot
water up against well you can get a
better shade you can use it for whatever
you'd like i think that the idea
for people who are washcloth users is
that they get in
all the cracks and crevices and nooks
and crannies with it
if that's the case then the order in
which you do it is very important this
was part of our debate because they
can't start with the ass
and then the face conan this was part of
our debate i said you
you folks who do this how often are you
swapping out the washcloth are you doing
a new one every day or does it just live
in the shower for a week
let me check this out this uh is a
christmas ornament yes sir that's a uh
that is me
riding donald um that's in riding donald
yes so on the show scrubs um there was a
whole stick we used to do where i'd ride
on his back and
we'd yell eagle and um and it was just a
stupid thing i improv
one episode and it became a fan favorite
thing so
now we have christmas ornaments with us
eagling on them
well what i'm going to do is i'm going
to put this on my christmas tree this
year better and i want you to send me a
picture i want you to lie i know
i i know your wife and i'm i'm going to
text her and say i thought you i thought
you were going to say i know you're a
liar
no i know you conan i know you're a liar
this is going on my tree
and i'll put this on my tree as well
after i use it
after you use it in the shower please
nice um nothing says christmas
washing your ass and hanging it on the
tree
um well i'm very happy for you uh i told
your producer that there's this very
funny gif
that on the web years ago i was on your
show and i was showing to
um your audience how i was able to be an
oz the great and powerful in a green
screen onesie and how it worked
and i stood up and then just being super
silly
i started humping the air and
there is the funniest gift that maybe
you guys can cut in or show that i
laugh at all the time because your your
face in andy's face is the funniest
thing i've ever seen
you're both slowly looking away so
uncomfortably
and i don't know if my my package or
moose knuckle or what's happening so i'm
covering it down there and i'm just
humping the air
yes i just had to share with you how
special that gif
is to me that's i see that in my mind
every night
as i try to go to sleep that's what puts
me out let me make sure i get the word
out you can listen to zack's podcast
a lot of you probably already are but
you should check it out if you're not
fake doctors real friends
wherever you get your podcast do you
guys read the ads
uh yeah we do read the ads and fun right
we turn down a bunch that we don't want
to do it's amazing the stuff they want
you to read and so we we
we're a little picky about what we'll
read right well you're the ones you turn
down
i do i'm like when you're looking for
really good meth
or seat belts are they really that
necessary right
there's a lot of that kind of those are
the ones i love doing uh anyway
zach so nice so nice talking to you and
thanks for being such a good man
over the years i salute you i bow to you
and hey when that movie does come out
it's called the comeback trail it should
be out next year when the world is
reopened and you can see me and bobby d
you know it'd be nice too um maybe by
the time it comes out
things will have changed a little bit
and you can come in and uh and and we'll
get together in person that'd be nice i
love that i would love to see your
beautiful face no
let's not get crazy don't forget to wash
your butt with my washcloth
i have it right here and it's not going
to leave my side all right zach braff
thank you very much
you